depuis deux mois et demi la rue
israélienne est en ébullition plus de 10
semaines de contestation contre la
réforme judiciaire voulue par le
gouvernement de Benyamine Netanyahou qui
souhaite annuler les décisions de la
Cour suprême par un vote majoritaire
simple du Tamar benkira
tard dans la nuit du lundi au mardi
l'acné s'est a approuvé en première
lecture le projet de loi
pour ce député de l'extrême droite c'est
très fort mettait indispensable et
bénéficie du soutien d'une large
majorité
le chef de fil du parti centre droit
déplore que la coalition gouvernementale
veuille surpasser la Cour suprême comme
si elle était l'ennemi de l'État
le président israélien Isa kerzog parle
d'une situation grave d'une crise
sociale et constitutionnelle à laquelle
il tente de trouver une solution Yakov
rapkin professeur d'histoire Montréal et
témoigne de ce clivage depuis Israël où
il se trouve en ce moment la société
seraienne tout entière
évolue vers la droite nationaliste vers
l'extrême droite voire et donc ce que
nous voir les résultats dans la cnset ce
n'est pas un hasard c'est une c'est le
résultat d'une tendance à long terme je
crois que remettre de l'ordre dans la
baraque c'est une bonne chose pour
Julien Bauer polytologue et auteur
au-delà de la façon de faire du
gouvernement Netanyahou la Cour suprême
a trop de pouvoir vous avez une cour
suprême qui il y a une trentaine
d'années a décidé qu'elle n'était pas
seulement la Cour suprême qui doit
s'assurer du respect des lois mais
qu'elle allait remplacer le législateur
le vrai pouvoir et en fait le pouvoir
des juges
le gouvernement reste sourd à la
mobilisation des manifestants qui
dénoncent une réforme antidémocratique
avait un système politique et juridique
dans lequel disons les institutions
judiciaires et en particulier la Cour
suprême jouer un rôle important dans un
cadre classique de séparation des
pouvoirs le projet de loi de Netanyahou
s'il est adopté donnerait plus de
pouvoir au gouvernement actuel ça veut
dire que une loi qui pourrait être par
exemple liberticide ou raciste et bien
pour être appliqué alors qu'aujourd'hui
elle ne peut pas donc c'est un enjeu
majeur la crainte elle vient du fait que
le gouvernement pour pouvoir avoir une
majorité est obligé de s'allier à des
petits partis et ces petits partis font
chanter quasiment le gouvernement
et dans ce cas-ci ce sont les parties
ultra orthodoxes et les parties
ultra-nationalistes qui sont là et ils
ont donc un nombre 10 proportionné de
poste et un nombre disproportionné de
ministère cette politique m'est traitée
la malle la démocratie
ça montre la force de la démocratie
israélienne elle est vraiment très très
forte les gens avancent c'est très
criard parfois c'est très violent etc
mais les départs sont très riches et
très importants alors si ces
manifestations vont arriver à freiner la
loi non mais peut-être
à la moduler quelque peu peut-être oui
on peut pas avoir à la fois un état qui
proclame la disons le privilège d'un
groupe par rapport à un autre et donc ça
ne peut pas être un État démocratique le
débat est là mais actuellement le
clivage n'est pas autour des droits de
Palestiniens n'ont pas autour de
territoire occupés c'est autour
justement de cette réforme qui a
focalisé les clivages du classicisme le
texte adopté en première lecture encore
deux autres étapes à franchir avant de
devenir lois le gouvernement accélère
son examen avant la fin de la session
parlementaire le 2 avril prochain ici
Radio-Canada Montréal